Governor Romney: Pay Equity for Women
Thank you.
And important topic and one which I learned a great deal about,...
...particularly as I was serving as governor of my state...
...because I had the chance to pull together a Cabinet...
...and all the applicants seemed to be men.
And I went to my staff and I said,...
..."How come all the people for these jobs are all men?"
They said, "Well, these are the people that have the qualifications."
And I said, "Well, gosh, can't we find some women that are also qualified?"
And so we took a concerted effort to go out and find women...
...who had backgrounds that could be qualified to become members of our Cabinet.
I went to a number of women's groups and said,...
..."Can you help us find folks?"...
...and they brought us whole binders full of women.
I was proud of the fact that after I staffed my Cabinet and my senior staff,...
...that the University of New York in Albany did a survey of all 50 states...
....and concluded that mine had more women in senior leadership positions...
...than any other state in America.